je vois vos talents oh là là ça n'a pas
l'air facile du tout
et comme il vaut mieux prévenir que
guérir
je vais demander tout de suite à
françois devenir m'aidiez à
l'eau à françois bonjour cm en art à
l'appareil peux-tu passer me voir tout
de suite ouais non j'étais un cochon a
demandé ouais merci à tout de suite
c'est ça ouais
un point de chose de faite alors qu'on
paie une bande de papier de 20 cm de
long un sentiment que l'on
[Musique]
a dû
y en a des meneurs je suis là pour
jean-françois c'est gentil d'être venus
si vite attend une seconde je n'ai pas
fini
ma léonard tu m'a fait venir pour me
demander quelque chose je crois oui oui
voila voila voila j'ai décidé de
fabriquer une fleur en papier pour julie
je n'y arrive pas le papier glisse les
sigean de coupât ils coupent de travers
alors je m'énerve je m'énerve je
m'énerve restent calmes c'est une très
bonne idée je suis sûr que julie serait
très contente oui c'est pour cela je
téléphonais pour que tu viens de m'aider
à bombay coûteux je vais te montrer
comment on fait
regarde je faire les pétales je foule le
papier crépon comme se situe à une paire
de ciseaux par la voix la garde je
coûtant fouet comme ça pour faire les
pétales et tu vois j'ai encore plusieurs
d'un seul coup voilà tu as compris on
sait jolie armes à moi à moi tiens
continue voilà et pendant ce temps là je
vais faire le coeur
c'est qu'un de la terre avec du papier
rose la jefferson
je coupe tout ce qui dépasse
la voile à composter
et il nous reste plus qu'à mettre le cul
voilà plein exactement comme ceux ci
aura la fille d'ozzy dalo militants là
et la fin est terminée elle est belle
françoise je n'ai plus qu'à la porte et
un à temps à julie je vais l'imposer
dans son kiosque pendant qu'elle n'est
pas là et je vais passer par mon tunnel
ce sera plus rapide au revoir voilà on
va revoir à tout à l'heure aux eaux
france - oui qui était la tête surtout
pas moins personnelle sur ce passé dans
ce premier
[Musique]
set petite promenade dans la forêt m'a
fait beaucoup de bien comme j'aurais
fait le ménage repartir je n'ai plus
qu'à installer tranquillement pour
prendre mon gloubiboulga
mais qu'est ce que c'est que ces saletés
moi je ne comprends pas j'avais pourtant
tout ranger avant de partir
leonard un renard
évidemment il n'est pas là
c'est sûrement un garnement qui a jeté
sa part la fenêtre
ouverte les mettre
dans la maille de léonard puisqu'il
n'est pas là hop voilà ni vu ni connu
bon alors en place pour le goûter
une assiette inverse pour ma grenadine
une force et un couteau
voilà
encore des papiers enfin je ne comprends
pas je viens de jeu vient d'orange et
qu'est ce que ça veut dire
aulas et jatte rappelé le garnement qui
me fait cette plaisanterie
voilà
pourquoi les maintenant le gloubiboulga
punaise je vais me régaler
quoi encore des papiers non mais ce
n'est pas possible enfin je vais me
mettre en colère
c'est sûrement une une mauvaise farce 1
ça ne va pas se passer comme ça
que se passe-t-il ici enfin qu'est ce
que c'est je vais à peine d'arriver je
t'entends qui écris tu as aimé il se
passe ça ne va pas du tout je viens de
faire mon ménage à fond ayant un mauvais
que les hommes jettent des papiers
regarde
bien on va voir s'il ya quelqu'un mais
j'ai déjà regardé par la fenêtre je n'ai
vu personne
que tu penses bien que le coupable
n'attend pas derrière alors tu crois bon
d'accord mais il faut d'abord que je
mette ses papiers
tiens pourquoi pas dans la corbeille à
papier
ça c'est une idée oui en effet voilà
bien
bon et bien maintenant mais il faudrait
que tu me garde mon gloubiboulga si ça
ne t'ennuies pas oui dans le mois vous
verrez cette fois là je vais me tenir en
attendant et je vais aller voir dans le
jardin c'est sûrement là bas que le
coupable se cache c'est ça sa honda de
trouver le coupable
ouais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas moi qui ai acheté des papiers
chez moi et sur
france soir oui je n'ai tu as vu casimir
oui les îles et dans le jardin oui je
sais bien qu'il ait d'un jardin mais
est-ce que tu l'a observé non pourquoi
bien via le regarder il a un
comportement étrange bien
on dirait qu'il cherche quelque chose ou
quelqu'un
des îles et
casimir casimir
d'écouté laissez moi tranquille je crois
que je suis sur une bonne piste a tu
vois qu'il est étranger du récent cas
quand les oreillettes
regarde françois
dans mon casque cette fleur splendide
n'était pas tout à l'heure en
effectivement je n'avais pas vu tu es
sûre qu'elle n'était pas là mais je sais
bien ce qu'il ya dans mon cas c'est ce
qu'il n'y a pas dans mon coeur 4 il dit
la m je sais c'est pas moi et tu étais
dans le jardin tout le temps je n'ai pas
bougé de la chaise alors si quelqu'un
était venu la porte et tu l'aurais eu
bien sûr
à moins que ce quelqu'un soit passer par
le tunnel ou mais c'est bien résonner sa
la seule personne qui peut passer par
les tunnels c'est leon mais bravo j'ai
passé trop gentil écoute garde vous
qu'est ce qu'un instant je veux le
remercier a entendu
casimir tiens voilà ton gloubiboulga tu
n'en as pas manger j'espère qu'en penses
tu j'ai mis un peu les doigts dedans
pour voir s'il ne refroidisse et pas
voilà très bien je n'ai pas trouvé le
coupable mais j'ai eu une très bonne
idée je vais prendre la corbeille à
papier me placer derrière la fenêtre et
dès que je l'entendrai approché hop tous
les papiers sur la tête
c'est une excellente idée ça il peut
toujours attendre longtemps pendant ce
temps-là mois
on ne fait pas de bruit léonard je
l'entends qui approche as tu vas voir il
va avoir une bonne surprise harry
vocation
hop
je vais aller voir le résultat tient
qu'à casimir c'est joli
cg
je juge que terna
n'y en a pas c'est toi toi mais je ne
sais pas ce qui m'est arrivé je ne vois
plus rien je vais te remercier à sa
place et toute ma famille et puis tout à
coup
casimir
[Musique]